[Musica]
è fatto
qualitativo
ai
non è vero o no ci sta scherzando
non è vero no non ci credo mai rimasta
scherza va bene questo perlomeno è che
era il naso brutto capito le frequenze
colori ma non potevo più fesso resistere
a vederti quella nov avete venduto io
che non ci credo
aironi che guardavo prezzo di no io sono
della polizia di credito smi
c'è un rosato tempo e arrivare da rai
[Musica]
ambulanza un colpo intensa e sole perché
ce l'ha con lui allora è bella domanda e
tu pensi
voglio cambiare personaggio fare io no
vesco e calci voler rompere ogni cosa
con un pezzo di imbarcati domestica
niente no madama sono stato io a far
diventare tutto dall'inizio
[Musica]
quando il rischio sopra nicchia io devo
lottare contro l'idea in finale cosa che
cosa parliamo
io posso parlarne no
[Musica]
mi ammazzo potrebbe fare tutti quando
adesso chiede che iniziano adesso soli
con me muori con gli oli o critiche con
me va bene a posto lo re adesso ci sarei
io dovessi andare di cosa parliamo
una follia ciccio che stiamo combattendo
l'uno contro l'altro si fa cc adesso io
dico che mi dispiace per in realtà non
mi dispiace davvero te lo dico solo per
farti metterci una pistola oggi però
iniziavano lido ecco gli tosto
noi non ce lo giuro lo farei mai
ma manco io che penso team credibile
avversario basta riscoprì ma io io io
ecco che sono usciti me stesso ma se la
passano succede adesso però sono sicuro
il sostituto mentre a schiaffi e tu ti
aspettano aspettami arrivo anch'io è che
sono mille sono tuo amico
e poi
[Musica]
chi è questa parte attiva di prima
quindi era nella polizia
questo arrivo io arrivo per l'elicottero
zio arrivo con l'elicottero
ciao dai mi sono uno sporco traditore
parti arrestare meriti di andare in
carcere lo sai ti sta facendo fuori
subito
ma sono io che devo fare io morire mai
dovresti saltare in aria non secondo
all'altro
già
ops
mamma mia mamma via arbe soltanto il
nemico principale 26 sempre state boss e
mi piace sentirmelo dire che non certo
tutti mai aiuto contro la marcia no
vincent
e lei presa porta come uccidere sei
anche un bravo ragazzo
dopo che un po scena gelo
cau
guerra
triste esistenza
[Musica]
ma che fa capo all di carlo 6 un po
preso male secondo me
no
non lo so forse spina il finale varia in
base a chi vince
ci sono due finali no
non è vero principio sicuro sarei
tentato di farmi ammazzare solo perché
voglio mio personaggio morto ma non lo
farò allora io con il mio cuore
spero che vinca tu però cuore però non
posso farti vincere perché se lo sarebbe
troppo brutto ridevo credo che faccio
impegnarmi no che finale ma credibile
mostra stati zitti mesi di gridare a
squarciagola o merda
la impegno anti ciccio so che ci puoi
fare di batterli ci sono di battermi di
ribatte amici cioè devi essere più forte
di me e batti mib attimi merito di
morire qua i meriti tu di vincere ma
lezione guarda qua
vorrei ridurre le mie capacità di sparo
ma non cose
donne dai scoperto da tutto
dai
ma va bene ed ha posto capitano a finire
vinco e traditore di merda
ti prego fammi no ma la sua vera vita
aveva ancora vita magari non è finito lo
scontro sicuro per forza maledetto pezzo
era bravo verona ma non fa una gran
tenerezza e fai comincia che piace a
mori mori mori morì fuori
no no no sempre quello legato di più
il ragazzo si vede non è non era finito
dai nevada quanto sai guarda quanto tali
di salute impegnati so che poi buster di
ciccio ce la puoi fare veramente una
canzone commoventi ma o no funghi no ti
prego a pugni c'è veramente perché o
meno vitaminici per forza tu siamo
arrivati qua sopra di tutto questo ce lo
stava proprio ce la siamo fronte lo
sapevano ma no dai non ce la faccio io
giuro
aia che male ma veri che ci sono delle
scene
sì sì sì sì sto ciò che veramente
assieme a quasi fai tu lo sta male ai
mezza vita io le ho un quarto cioè e ma
tu sei più strong trovo un po morire
meno male che ci sei tu che sono mister
venuto da piangere fortissimo cazzo si
tantissima pervenuto da più o meno male
che ci sei tu che mi tieni tu te casto
sviluppo che mai quest'anno fatto male
ha detto veramente disperate queste
parente triste dai
anche dolore l'ultima è l'ultima botta è
l'ultima decisiva mazza cosa ha
costruito un fenomeno
che il nonno
però è vero e ciccio riccio dai ciccio è
maleducazione
perché tu sei meglio e vito rispondera
interesso male no l'ho preso io
addio no funziona come si fa non ci
riesco a te lo giurano di s no ti voglio
bene cg di cortona
no ho vinto io che tristezza che non sia
mai detto no tav no ho vinto io perché
ho vinto i no dai
cosa
[Musica]
per
madonna che tristezza dov'è ma meno male
che ci sono meno male che ci sei tu che
sono certo solo da solo da solo una
prevendita
[Musica]
no mi spiace però
cambio già da baseball iniziate solo
d'insieme turci qua madonna rega barbaro
e così il 20 delle famiglie a bastardo o
ci sono straw marito questa tua famiglia
[Musica]
ehi
sai che c'è
[Musica]
ai box
l'ice l'enit gioca
[Musica]
ok parole il cesto del 6
non poteva essere più bravo a sparare
non hai giocato giochi fps non giova da
come questo ora il mio pc non può
veramente veramente un po cosa vuol dire
dai miss marple ci guarda cominciata ma
che finale di merda dai non ci posso
credere
ma questo avuto anche le pantere da suo
fratello ucciso io ma non penso che
abbia detto davvero provare da come il
socialista incazzando penso che abbia
incassato di più
chissà che adesso mi sa che glielo ha
detto
[Musica]
dai che ti stai a qualche danno fatto
affezionare in un certo modo ai
personaggi per tutto a leo dell air un
grande dopo
[Musica]
mamma
naso lungo ma sincero credo non faccio
immergo e fa finta di essere board
processo alla allora io non sapevo mi
sarei suicidato molto prima io sto qua
sua moglie
è sicuramente dirà no ed i negozi è
stato quello è vero o no una lettera
soccer o bicchieri schemi one world
girls tenendo joy securifor lei che ci
sta il resto
[Musica]
lo sai
new york
il karma dovrebbe punirmi ad essere
sinceri no dai
no no no no un palo fuori dai ma time
buttalo fuori perfetto no finisce
pensiamo a noi c'è il funerale di leo
no
c'è solo la moglie drago
leo caruso daino poverino 73 vendita
e ambientale 72 26 mar significa si
vestì di sì
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma doveva doveva andare con c'e nel
senso tu potevi veramente vincere lo
scontro
beh non lo so io penso che comunque se
fossi sopravvissuto ceppo e questo l'ho
solo ora no dai vabbè c'è
[Applauso]
il sapore chiuderlo questo spirito ci
credo io ho seguito in una serie così
come questo di ma non sono stato io ma a
saperlo ma neanche massa per lo facevo
la guardia che mi menava l'inizio da te
lo giuro
posso parlare lo iscritti esatte soges
come rino quello che a tutti gli
iscritti a lui ne ha 4 milioni la cosa
bella sapete cos'è che non solo da 4
milioni e braille chiamate in culo
palesemente fortissimo ma pure vorrei
finire questa bella 600 ragazzine colpa
vieste coppa dice rosa sparare bene non
cresce ed un pestaggio e fa schifo
però paio di proiettili messi meglio
facevi metterle se proprio quegli occhi
giornali però va bene stendiamo un velo
pietoso
verissimo posso dire altro va bene io
non so cosa dire spero vi siano fashion
giorno grazie
la serie vi si va bene sono a parte gli
scherzi che bombace da novanta era stato
belli non me l'aspettavo mai perché io
spero che la serie vi sia piaciuta però
che non ci avviate con me perché io non
ho scelto di fare questo ci diamo poi un
bacino
io te lo do sul naso ok
spero che la servizi è piaciuta come al
solito si vede che ci hanno messo mi
piace anche al protagonista
nell'edizione so se avessi studiato al
che servito da ragazzi
[Musica]